foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
genomic biomarker for predicting
response in early breast cancer patients
this webinar is part of the 2022 cancer
research and immuno oncology virtual
week
I am Liz Pitts of nanostrink and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
nanostring for more information about
nanostrink including the panels being
featured here today please go to
nanastring.com
with that let's get started before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
the live chat feature during the
presentation you can find the live chat
located at the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask the question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
and I now present today's speaker Dr
Maggie Chan team leader of Integrative
genomic analysis in clinical trials at
The Institute of cancer research in
London for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the left of your screen and with that
I invite you Dr Chan to begin your
presentation
thank you very much I would like to
thank you everyone for attending the
talk today and also thank you Nano's
drink
for inviting me to give a talk and share
some of our research work with a wider
audience
so here I just want to give a little bit
brief introduction in terms of my
research approach and also my team I
lead a multi-disciplinary team with a
focus on combining molecular pathology
and data Sciences
and with this it offers a complementary
expertise to various stakeholders
um achieving forward translation which
is bench to bedside and or reverse
translations
um that is best signed to bench talk in
cancer research but particularly my team
is specialized in machine learning deep
learning methods and spatial biology
here's the outline of my talk first I
will start by giving a brief
introduction of the research approaches
my team applied a little bit more uh
kind of give you a kind of an
introduction in terms of how do we do
the the science
um and then at the same time I will
focus on some examples of the breast
cancer field where to illustrate my team
how we actually advise apply Advanced
Analytical approaches for clinical
genomic statuses and in order to develop
multi-parametric biomarker algorithm
maximizing the impact on translational
genomics so you would focus on ER
positive breast cancer in this context
so um artificial intelligence is a very
trendy word now and there are different
AI branches and in general we can
categorize them based on their own
functionalities as you can see in this
slide
and the area of my research is the
machine learning and under machine
learning you can find several categories
supervised learning and supervised
learning we enforcement and learning and
deep learning generally these are the
four main categories
so before I actually do this
presentation I Google machine learning
update last week when I was thinking
about how to put this together and I
found this Twitter message tag um
10-year challenge Avenue was the man as
a sarcasm but it really reflects how we
the few use this term loosely at this
moment as you can see that um in 2009 we
this is a simple statistics but now
people would have considered that as a
machine learning which I just but I want
to mention that this is not the machine
learning approach that I was referring
to put this in perspective on the right
I showed the typical machine learning
methods that my team use as a as
appropriate depending on the research
questions for example uh whether um for
classifications or clustering we use a
different methods which is on the right
and then usually using this machine
learning methods we look for molecular
patterns or identify new molecular
biomarkers and then model these
molecular circles with patient outcome
to develop a a a predictor algorithm or
prognostic biomarker signature so I I um
so it's more like um
patient outcomes in trial to develop
multi-parametric biomarker signatures
and in my experience I'm developing such
kind of algorithms tend to be a more um
generalizable and also be a more robust
signatures
and this also um some people may ask
what type of Market signatures have been
used this approach and this brings to my
disclosure I'm a co-inventor of the Pam
50 Pro signal essay which is licensed in
20 uh sorry 2009 which is an example of
news and integrated analytical approach
and was available since 2013 in the
clinic as you can see that on the lab
which first um first left you see that
it was actually using a machine learning
approaches where we identify list of
best candidates of genes that actually
can recapture the intrinsic subtypes
then we apply statistical modeling of
these algorithms with patient outcome to
come up with a week with some recurrence
score
um this together approach come with the
pro signal approach
given um apologize if I had the nest
feels like I want to give a little
internal content in intrinsic subtyping
because
um in order to give a little bit more
context in terms of the um uh and the
rest of my slides
um the discovery of the intrinsic
supplies has been considered as major
research advance for breast cancer by
American Society of clinical oncology
and um people who may be very involved
in breast cancer research field as
audience may already vary a much
used to this line or if you attend San
Antonio breast cancer symposes almost
you will hear the intrinsic sometimes
all the time but just in in a little bit
in terms of brief introduction is that
using Global gene expression profiling
um my personal supervisor Chuck Peru at
that time into year 2000 he can identify
that based on a list of genes are
actually showing highest barriers across
unique samples or constant samples but
showing little variance between pair
samples of patients hence called
intrinsic list of genes you can actually
molecularize that breast cancer into at
least five breast cancer subtypes
showing different molecular content
mainly with pneumonoul a numinal B
although they are both ER positive
tumors they are associated with
significantly different differential
survival as you can see from the right
couple of my curve on the top right
um dark blue color is actually luminal a
compared with luminobi in an untreated
cohort you actually have significantly
different survival outcome basal light
and her2 average subtype are typically
associated with worse outcome you know
untreated cohort patients but with how
to every subtype with a lot of work
um
for my my group
um and also Chuck's group and also Lisa
carries research from Nissan carry and
also from Alaska have demonstrating
their her2 and receptile do predict
better to predict response for her to
anti-hur to targeted therapy
but in two in terms of how does
proceeding and pump 50 work in the
algorithm was that we develop we
identify optimal lists of 50 genes that
actually recapitulate the five intrinsic
subtypes pneumonoul a numeral B number
like her2 and receptile and basal like
we come up with an average profile we
call it centroid that actually represent
the prototypical of samples and the
algorithm take in is that if you
actually have one single sample coming
in from from the connect
um as a or as an experiment research
used only as a you we take that 50 genes
panel and then apply the signatures and
then you compare the
um the molecular profile of your sample
with this individual or this average
profile and we determine how close it is
related to each of this prototypical
centroid and the highest correlation to
that protocol you will be assigned to
the subtype hence in this tumor you can
see that it's luminal a showing that you
have the highest correlation coefficient
to a typical luminal a algorithms
give a little bit better in terms of the
type of typical approach and then the
sounds I have used in this algorithm
sorry this type of analytical approaches
in previous work done um that I have
done I'd like to start talking about
some two applications that I have uh um
published with my group teamwork with a
lot of my collaborators and teams in UK
in town in turn how to address some of
these uh important clinical questions
um the first one is the molecular
changes in response to endocrine therapy
within ER positive her2 negative breast
cancer
so over 80 percent of breast cancer
patients in develop Western world have
estrogen reception positive disease and
then the treatment normally indicates uh
surgery and Edge of an endocrine therapy
and sometimes chemotherapy which greatly
improves survival outcome
so multi-parametric Gene
expression-based prognostic signatures
are often used to estimate the residual
risk of recurrence after surgery to
guide patient management
and amongst the most widely used
prognostic signature in a positive
breast cancer the oncotype DH recurrence
goal and predict and pro signal risk of
risk of recurrence goal
to and before I go into the molecular
categorization I also want to give a
little bit um introduction in terms of
the type of window opportunity trials
that we run in UK and there's some of
these typical typical trials that run in
U.S and actually try to adjust and try
to identify molecular characterization
that can predict endocrine therapy
response poetic trial is a pre-surgical
treatment
trials where to to develop whether
patient or the child original design
need to eval whether a patients
have received perioperative endocrine
therapy would um improve the survival
outcome
and the trial have the second objective
to try is also to validate to look at
whether changes of k67 which is we as a
proliferation index would um have an
indicator biomarker to predict the
survival outcome for patients
so the main results of the poetic are we
reported have indicating that two weeks
of power operative
um and the quad therapy did not improve
the survival outcome however
by measuring the q67 at Baseline
on the left of Jefferson and then
measuring the q67 of the repair
operative Keys underground therapy
if you are actually on the right if you
look at the couple Minecraft within year
positive her2 negative tumors if you are
actually having k67 at low risk so at
the adjust uh biopsy and then after the
two weeks of para operative which is
remain lowest so low low you actually
associate with super good survival
outcome
when you are actually high risk which is
sorry High expression of k67 but you
your q67 reduce uh less than 10 which is
the low risk
um in terms of local you are now uh your
Capital my Curve Your survival outcome
is almost as close as to the low low
group like H and L
and now unfortunately if you actually
have high q67 value
um before the treatment and remain high
hence there's no reduction of
proliferation after the two weeks of
endocrine therapy you remain should be
harassed having um
uh five years uh recurrence risk at
almost 20 percent
hey Maggie I'm sorry to cut you off it
looks like your webcam is Frozen do you
want to just turn it off and turn it
back on really quick
to see if that resets it
okay do you see me
Liz are you able to see it I don't know
if it's on my end my internet's been
very weird today so I don't know if it's
just me
I don't see any um
image of anything
any cameras do I have right here
okay
uh for me it's frozen but let me give me
one second let me just double check to
see if it is me I'm gonna sign into the
same
browser maybe in a different browser
here hold on one second
thank you
okay it looks like you're fine when I
logged into a different browser so it
might just be my internet so sorry about
that let's just go ahead and continue
the talk
um and then when we do the edits and
stuff of course I'll edit this out but
it looks like your camera is fine I
don't know why it's weird on my end I
apologize it's important for everyone to
see
like I don't want to be myself looking
so focused like with a mouth open and
everyone should see that with my mouth
open absolutely yeah and I I don't want
to refresh because I think that that
might stop the recording so um I'm just
gonna look at it through the second
browser just to monitor it on that end
um but go right ahead and continue I
know you just finished this slide so if
you want to restart on that slide you
can or if you want to just go ahead and
go to slide 17 uh you can go ahead and
do that as well
no I think I will go to the next slide
okay fabulous then go right ahead and
start whenever you're ready
so now after explaining that it looks
like in Poetic
um which is uh it actually validate that
changes of key six seven within year
positive hurt your negative tumor tumor
is
um
in terms of the reduction of Keystone
seven is a as a market where it could be
telling us in terms of early indication
in terms of whether the patient will
have increased risk of recurrence and I
would call it as a surrogate as an early
resistance to aromatase inhibitor
so now why is it is important and then
trial would be it would be a great
resource for us to look at molecular
categorization
um here you can it's a pie chart that I
took from
um a large Plant group in 2018 where
they have done um Pam 50 on big cohort
of patient and they look at in terms you
can see that you you can see intrinsic
subtype distribution amount different
subgroups on the left you see a hormone
receptor positive her to negative tumors
and Then followed by hormone receptor
positive and her2positive and then homo
receptor positive her2 neck uh Plus or
negative Advanced disease consider that
the distribution of pneumonouliminal B
her2 and receptive change slightly
different according to that um pie chart
distribution at the same at the same
time you're also indicating that
um just using hormone receptor positive
and her2 negative tumors would not help
you to actually recapitially intrinsic
subtyping
and that brings to the the interesting
questions that I I my first paper
published in the clinical cancer
research that I was going to discuss
today why was to give a little bit
context why it was in uh in my mind it
was an interesting question to uh to
Yvette was that the prognostic value of
changing the proliferation index as
measure in
um in poete have been validated so
decreased tumor cell expression of k67
is now often used as a proxy for
treatment response such as early effect
to endocrine therapy with a pre-surgical
window opportunity trials a new elephant
clinical trials for new experimental
drugs
and Matthew Ellis group have identified
targetable immune checked bonding
components
um regulated in the majority of
endocrine therapy resistance
um treated with more than four weeks
unumino B cases and providing a
rationale for email immlo therapy
inhibition in poor outcome year positive
breast cancer
however
um
q67 clinical and pathological endpoints
may not be sufficient to measure the
effect of new atrogen regimens such as
seeding forces inhibitor for pneumonia
breast cancer
and practice now propels the use of
conversion from pneumonou B to numino a
type and or a reduction of our outscore
as an alternative measure of treatment
activity and it was published in the
currently study and this is
currently in study evaluate the activity
of new Adrian treatment with
um with either a center combination
chemotherapy
um
or an investigational drug combination
in this context is natural plus variable
cyclop to molecular than station numeral
B yeah positive her2 negative tumors the
study is very well conducted and is
really a biological oriented
um
biological Rich trials with biomacker
driven kind of M poem which is making
sense because if you have reduction from
lumino B to numino a
you are generally associated with better
survival outcome
um however
there are no compare comparison have
been done on the effect of different
lengths of neoadjuvant aromatous
inhibitor therapy in molecular features
and it may be necessary to elicitate the
full impact on molecular authorization
that may limit response and lead to
clinical resistance hence
um that comes that was the idea that I
would like to investigate whether a
duration of neo-andruffin endocrine
therapy would have impact how the
molecular changes hence the backbone for
all these experimental drugs in the
appository her2 negative tumors
um so using Global gene expression
profiles from the the poetic trial
um within the arm who actually received
two weeks of aromatous inhibitor
we um and also 47 receive who have not
received any treatments so we have done
a global gene expression on the iron and
later samples so using the micro rate
and also we use Target gene expression
profile from 80 patients with pair
sample treated with new atrophone and
nuclear for more than one month for
mobile mastering hospital so you will
want the real world data and I call it
new AI study in the study so in this
study we evaluate the intrinsic
subtyping modules on covering different
kinds of pathway and your new related
genes
um for a pre-treatment and post
treatment tumors and aim to evaluate how
the length of the duration of endocrine
fabric will have impact these molecular
components
so here you can see that on the left
um this slide indicate the differences
in the intrinsic subtyping
classification from Baseline to surgery
compared with the in the context of
poetic subset and then although new
adjuvant studies so Leo sorry Neo ASL on
the right poetic is on the left so two
weeks versus more than one month if you
treat it with endocrine therapy in
summary in Poetic the treaty cohort
mostly not be too much at Baseline
um 90 percent
and 50 of the hurricane Irish were
redesigned as numeral a or numeral or
normal like subtype whereas 42 percent
of hurricane average and most luminal a
which is 85 percent and vasolatumas
remain and change after two weeks of a
Methodist inhibitor
on the right similar to Poetic trial in
the new AI study most women will be two
months which is 76 of the pneumino B
tumors were redesigned as pneumonou a or
normal like at only 13.2 percent remain
unchanged while 10.5 percent were
classified as a basil like or her2 and
result type and 50 of Heritage supplies
remain as hard to enrich while 20 were
designated to nominal a and thirty
percent to normal like so overall the
differences in intrinsic subtype
classification were comparable after the
new edge of an endocrine therapy
regardless of the duration of the
therapy
so although the total numerical changes
in the new AI studies seems to be appear
higher compared with the treated samples
in the poetic which is in the case 68
versus 38 but this is likely probably
due to a higher proportion of pneumonou
B tumors at Bayside in the Neo AI study
uh remember the new AI is a real world
data where we actually retrieve blocks
from Walmarts and hospital where
patients have been treated with new
atrophone endocrine fabric which tend to
be a little bit more high-risk tumors
according to clinical grade by the
clinician hence pneumono B which makes
sense as well
so now given a lot
in endocrat 5 a new edge of an
endercraft in most of the changes is
actually within the numeral B tumor who
is supposed to be endocrine sensitive
tumors so what we want to also focus is
to look at those who were classified as
the name will be from the pre-treatment
biopsies so fickle on the left
illustrates the changes with the nominal
B tumors at Baseline after two weeks of
our methods inhibitor and that the
tumors were increasingly more similar to
political luminal a and normal light
tumors at a two week standpoint now just
to remind
um it feels like ahead I was explaining
how the Pam 50 assigning the the
intrinsic subtype so now you if you look
at this plot
uh on the far right and far left sorry
you can see the t67 value at Baseline
and then each of the column follow you
see that the subtyping that is the
correlation coefficient so that and the
row is actually is the samples
so
if this numino B you can see that most
of the correlation coefficient to
luminal B is high like as indicate in
the pan 50
um you can see the color bar Prime 50
[Music]
um
um the top I read and then the is
positive correlation and then blue is
negative correlation
see that most of this is actually having
um the red positive highest correlation
to nominal B at the Baseline
now at after the two weeks sample uh two
two reason therapy this tumor will
redesigned will classified as numinal a
and you can see that actually now the
correlation coefficient to numeral a is
positive and then the correlation
coefficient to numeral B reduce and also
with the other subtyping at the same
time on the far right
um You can see that the key 67 value
also reduce now this is how you in Turn
Practice plot so you can see that most
of the nominal B do actually have the
concept um there's
most likely because of polarization
genes reduce hence the classification
characteristics or that tumor becomes
slightly more in terms of the more
similar to nominal a
so similar to Poetic atrial in a new AI
study figure on the right after more
than one month you can see the most
pneumonal B tumors were reclassified as
luminal a
um and 10 were classified as her2 and
receptile
so indicating that most of them is
actually still is other proliferation
and reduction and whether you actually
treat them longer that you can actually
bringing them to more normal like and
luminal a tumors that is quite an
interesting question that we are now
next to evaluating them
but at the same time we are not just
interested in terms of interested
subtyping as a classification we also
want to look at more deep in terms of
the individual Gene and then the
particular features so we'll compare the
differential expression of genes in
common between the both data sets and
they are shown here so on the um on the
bottom uh excesses is the full change
between the Baseline surgery from the
Neo AI study and the y-axis is the
lawful change of the genes on um on the
power of and in the poetic study
so on the left is azure all cohort on
the right is the plot on the pneumono B
tumors
so in in general at the single Gene
level along the course of new actual
endocratic do have high impact on the
expression of immune related genes
and to look into a little bit more
details is that genes from the first
Gene modules are Mac
um ERC pi3 kinase akt jack stand pathway
and igf-1 involved in tumor growth and
resistance to our motives Inhibitors
were up regulated in both studies which
is consistent to mechanisms of endocrine
therapy most of the dumb regulated genes
in common were involved in cell cycle
regulation and proliferation so a higher
number of genes change significantly
from Bayside to surgery after longer
term treatments and compare with shorter
AI therapy in the overall population
um
one thing that was interesting is that
although full changes were higher highly
correlated between the two data sets the
magnitude of changes for individual
genes in Poetic microarray data was
smaller compared with the new AI Nano
string data Matrix
what is most important on this study in
my opinion is that when we start to
investigate whether the change of immune
related features associated with
resistance to aromatous inhibitor by
duration of new atrophone underground
therapy two immune related modules score
were calculated specifically and shown
here the development signature was
identified by your Mercury
which is taking a median or pdr1 Lac 3
and cxcl9
that was previously reported to respond
to immunotherapy in melanoma
and the other signature which is the
immune tolerance signature by Matthew
Ellis group is taking the median of pdr1
Lab 3 and idle on one it is um it was
reported by Matthew that it is
associated with resistance on which is
inhibit numeral B tumors and in the new
Adrian setting so here you should see
the bus part showing the changes in gene
expression from Baseline to surgery of
these two modules on the left is the
poetic
and on the right is the new Aisa so in
the poetic subset on the left you can
see that the high expression of
development signature and you immune
tolerance signature was associated with
tumors that show high high case example
so the resistant early resistant AI
tumors and it does something no
significant changes of the signatures
expression from base onto surgery was
seen in either high high or high low
categories on the other hand in a new AI
cohort there was also a high expression
of the new immune related signatures in
the high high tumors compared with the
high low as Baseline with a differential
increase in the expression of the
development signature and the immune
tolerance signature from the Baseline to
surgery from the high low tumors so the
sensitive tumors compared with the high
high tumors
so gather that what how do I interpret
is that although the expression of both
the immune significant signatures as
surgery we make significantly higher in
high high tumors compared with hylo in
the poetic substance it was not
significantly different after long-term
AI therapy
and the the fact that the association of
the change of the individual genes
included in the two immune related
module score with resistance to AI was
also a sense our resource suggested that
the enrichment on pdl1 after longer AI
may be the key driving the differences
between the responders and
non-responders in the new AI studies
so in summary
short and long-term AI treatment have
similar effects to the change of the
intrinsic subtype classification
suggesting that
using it as a biological endpoint as a
large part have done or in terms of
um that is actually validated
longer neoadjuvant however longer new
Azure fan AI treatment do leads to
deeper impact on molecular
characterizations changes in gene
expression beyond the intrinsic subtypes
including signatures covering your
immune checkpoint component reported
previously associated with AI early
resistant tumors
some of the observe changes such as
changes in the intrinsic subtype or
enrichment of gaming features were shown
not only associated with response to our
limited HIPAA but also with patient
outcome thus providing a supporting
rationale to consider the continuation
with an endocrine therapy to higher risk
tumors if changes in transcriptional
signatures are desired finally further
investigation on the use of the immune
checkpoint component inhibition and this
Statin could be warranted and um I hope
that the biological finding from this
type of molecular categorization can
help to inform a better child design
now I will quickly talk about a recent
publication that we have Publics on the
molecular catheterization and predicting
endocrine Fabric in a a rare collection
from ER positive her to positive tumors
so 15 of all breast cancer over Express
her2 and approximately 50 of these are
hormone receptor positive tumors these
tumors have substantial difference in
biology and clinical outcome from year
positive her2 negative tumors and
unfortunately resistance to endograph
therapy have made been mainly studied in
year positive Heritage breast cancer
um which reported that down regulation
or estrogen resumption expression author
um coagulation presentation to year
mutation have been reported to play the
role as also I demonstrated in the
previous side however this mechanism May
differ if you are actually between her
two positive tumor and her two negative
tumors impact due to the differential
distribution of the intrinsic substance
within each breast cancer subgroup as I
mentioned earlier in some of the slide
and how to talk to the therapies may be
fail to negate the importance of
development of resistance to AI in this
hard to process subgroup but while
anti-hearted therapy is generally given
for no more than one year to primary
breast cancers endocrine fabric is given
for at least five years to year person
her2-positive tumors so therefore any
residual heritu positive disease after
the end of the Heritage therapy we make
that risk of ending complete endocrine
response so poetic trial which also yeah
we could earphones her to positive tumor
provide a perfect framework for us to
use to study endocrine resistant
mechanism in this rare cohort
so he is a a big overview in terms of
the ongoing translational program that I
have um take in the year positive her to
positive core in Poetic a trial and
including multi-ohmake studied
um Technologies I'm going with all these
cohort and modeling the data that we are
going to generate um do integrative
multi-ohmics and the patient outcome
machine learning but today one I would
like to focus is the paper that we focus
on the Baseline tumors and um the ex um
in the context of poetic
uh focus on the work on the Baseline
tumors and all the available yeah to
positive breast cancer Baseline
um the number is 342 cases where gene
expression profile using the bc360 Nano
string covering the entrances supplies
and 46 key biological signatures and
early response to AI was assessed By
changes in key z7 expression and
residual key 67 in two weeks so either
as a two weeks
as a single M I'm sorry a single
variables or in terms of the changes and
also time to recurrence was estimated
using copper Maya methods and cost
regression models adjusting with
standard clinical variables but at the
same time we also apply machine learning
methods to identify more new molecular
subgroups
so here is uh the most important slide
um or
in the study or the Highlight is that we
evaluate whether the intrinsic subtypes
could predict respond to endocrine
therapy and in the entire substance of
patient 45 of tumors were classified as
her2 every subtype 36 aluminum B 70
luminal a and only two percent are basal
like two months
and in addition the proportional
engineering subtitles were comparable
between the control so that is that um
that actually have not received the two
weeks of endocrine therapy
um with the um with the treated groups
with uh with the control slightly
enriched with her to average 54 versus
41 in the treatment group and reduce
luminal a tumors eight percent versus 21
but these differences is not
statistically significant but most
important because we have done both
treated and control we can do this
proper predictive value evaluation
so with the within the traitor subgroups
31 achieve good response 22 23 were
intermediate response and 46 percent of
poor response while 52 had key six seven
um at um two weeks I considered to a
high which is more than 10 and 48 are
low I expected most control tumors were
classified as per response which is 96
because you do not expect that they will
have reduction of key success level
hence validating the importance of the
control in terms of taking care of the
artifacts if we are looking at the
individual Gene signatures
um which you read the details in the
paper they explain a little more of the
artifacts which I do not have time to
present today unfortunately
but in the Twitter group there was a
significant change in q67 values in all
subtypes
except for basal light tumor possibly
due to the small sample number overall
the 100 and reception was assured with
poor response to AI compared to know how
to enrich
um and also
um is uh so we're validating that how to
and receptive is as a predictive marker
too early resistance q67
um
at the same time we actually find new
identify five new molecular subgroups
based on the consensus clustering of the
tumors using the expression of the 758
genes from the bc360 top panel you can
see that illustrator single gene
expression of all genes in treated
samples with the t67 data
separate separated by the five Noble for
subgroups the clustering of these genes
are annotated according to the
functionality
and bottom panel you can see that
illustrates the expression levels of the
21 multiple
signatures ordering a coordinated new
five molecular subgroups
so this is a heat map ordered by the
five molecular subgroups and then you
can see that most of the gene signature
actually with the same function actually
entity M same annotated functions is
actually clustered together as well
typically the molecular feature of the
cluster c one C2 and C3 were categorized
by PR
to a poor response to aromatic inhibitor
and Chi k67 so now you're looking at the
top panel how you actually interpret the
the different kind of how they actually
um each of the cluster groups associated
with the response so now these molecular
subgroups either were identified purely
based on the biology so you're just
looking at the biology patterns and you
we identify five biological supplies
among these patients but this biological
subgroup do show differences in terms of
response to q67 and survival outcome
and
now if you look at C2 cluster 40 of the
total of their entire group had higher
levels of extracellular Matrix
organization related genes lower levels
of ESL engine and the highest levels of
her2 Gene level mRNA or B2 and Oxford
when distributed by subtypes
C3 had low expression of most genes but
a slight up migrator of genes covering
DNA damage repair deficiency
and C4 and C5 were categorized by good
response to aromatous inhibitor and as
expected an enrichment of pneumonoul
tumors
so both women are subgroups over Express
ER signal language genes however while
C4 had the highest level of esr1 Gene C5
was enriched with genes involved in Mac
kinase and rest signaling
so now if you when we run couple of my
curve of this molecular sub curves you
can see that they actually are
associated with significantly different
outcome
and most importantly we actually
separate the her2 and resupply into two
different subtypes groups which is quite
very interesting
um because based on bulk RNA sequence we
also do RN sequencing for these tumors
most of the characteristics looks
we can be recaptulated by looking at the
bc360 so um so what is intro now we are
looking at maybe
the difference is can we actually look
at um spatial proteins where that we can
actually look at why there's a why the
differences in terms there's a
difference it is hard to Emery subtype
with the survival outcome
so this comes to my concluding uh as a
last slide where
um uh this is ongoing big projects that
we are looking at is that is now we
recognize that with both RNA sequencing
and our Nano string we are able to
molecular categorize tumors into
different categorization and then we can
use it to predict endocrine therapy
resistance but at the same time we've
noticed that we're actually looking at
intra tumor hydrogenity and also because
of the immune reading signatures we are
interested to look at how the tumor
micro environment uh interact with the
cancer cells so now we actually have
this ongoing
um uh using the digital spatial
profiling whole transcriptomic on some
extreme responder extraordinary cases
that we are trying to unders to to
discover what is the difference and how
that has actually explained the
difference and then we are collaborating
with mobile Sagano for helping us to
actually identify the key um differences
areas and we are now doing whole
transcriptomic analysis
um this this is an example where I took
in terms of a pose Ai and pre AI you can
see that actually different areas laid
up by the morphological kids and then
um
with your transcription make signature
they actually also explains the
differences why this is uh so
I'm very excited but um I don't have the
data to show today and I will show next
time but in summary
um this is
um we indicated with this paper we have
demonstrating that combined
investigation or intrinsic subtypes and
those new molecular subgroups may be key
for the selection of candidate patients
for escalator and the escalate postures
in the future in the context is the
escalator could be a numeral a or novel
circle with the immune features that we
have I have just described within the
and positive here to positive subgroup
and escalator if they are hard to
unrespective and we are positive her to
positive tumors so in summary using this
integrated multi-oh mix analysis and
machine learning approaches we can
identify normal
multi-parametric gene expression
signatures and inform neutral design and
also hopefully we can identify novel
more receptacles with clinical where to
be on intrinsic subtype and integrating
with spatial genomics hydrogen will
offer new insights to treatment response
and obviously this is teamwork and I
would like to thank all my colleagues
and um my colleagues with the clinical
trials Union who actually uh is
responsible for running many of the
trials including poetic and also my
close collaborator from the breast
cancer division at The Institute cancer
research and also the uh thank you for
the most importantly is the patient who
actually have participated in the trials
um and our funders so thank you for
listening and now um that concludes my
presentation
thank you so much Dr Chan for uh joining
us today and sharing your insights into
the breast cancer research here we're
now going to start the Q a portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now you can do
that by clicking on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen all right let's get started
question sending coming in first one for
you Dr Chan some research groups tend to
apply machine learning on the molecular
features optimized with outcome for
example training against patient outcome
what do you think about this approach
um I think this is a a nice approach as
well and I think applying for this
approach I think it would be best if you
actually have a very clear clinical
question because you are basically
optimize your molecular features a
selection
based on patient outcome so Uncle type
is one of the the nice assets that I
really like is that they come up with a
very clear clinical question that they
want to be looking for features that is
actually predicting to to uh resource
currents for
yeah positive tumors
um which is very nice but it's also
um yeah coffee of this approaches that
limit in terms of generalization so for
example
um
You probably can only apply for another
cohort that actually treated the same
way because you are optimizing the
outcome
um so it is actually a different
approach and I have taken I always go
with biological inside interests
identify inside difference and then try
to see if actually these molecular
patterns that we observe competing
outcome and generally that actually
helps to more generalizable
for example Pam 50 people have
demonstrated that the intrinsic subtypes
constant also apply for bladder cancer
and also prostate cancer which is
actually is because everything is driven
by biology
perfect thank you for that Insight uh
the next question do you focus your
research on only ER positive breast
cancer
not really I actually the breast cancer
is is
my um
passion
so today I only focus on yeah uh
positive breast cancer
um but I also run a several uh research
study on the triple negative breast
cancer
um so I have a student actually looking
at triple necklace breast cancer in the
advanced something
um and I what I'd like to start is also
it gives me a a an opportunity to look
at breast cancer in a in a global wheel
for example how the
immune features the expression mini
feature in the context of associate with
patient outcome and to protect treatment
response is just
by opposite if I say
um is the way that how they uh pronoun
so for example prognostic effect of
Tails or
um is positive is a positive marker for
triple natural breast cancer in year
positions but at the same time uh the
immune features is actually all those is
predicting to resistant to uh Olympus
inhibitor but they are associated with
good outcome so that is still kind of um
uh Synergy uh regarding between these
two type of subgroup in terms of
relation in terms of how does the immune
micro environment efficient that brings
a lot of interesting inside how we can
actually put this together so so I yeah
so I like to look at everything in
breast cancer
um and try to integrate all these all
mixed data together but analyze them
separately
all right perfect and it looks like
we're going to have time to take one
more question here it's a really
interesting one uh that came in on
spatial work here today you presented
most of your work on bulk transcriptomic
data and you touched on a point
regarding spatial transcriptomic work
what do you think about the future of
this technology in terms of clinical
implication
I
because I am a very multi uh on my uh
machine learning
I would say I love data so my research
is always data and and I more data this
better and help us to molecularize that
more and it's actually fantastic whether
it was whether it's a spatial in terms
of DSP or even just Multiplex free
marker on multi-immered fluorescent it
gives us more insight in terms of
looking at combining morphology
and also how does tumors and immune
cells presenting together each other is
very fantastic and it actually help us
to actually help me in the context and
how to explain why two tumor actually
have the same type of bulk rna-seq or
dna-seq expression and then they just
act differently in terms of treatment
response so I do think that there is a
great implication when we are starting
to look at this spatial for
um clinical implication specifically for
the
um extraordinary tumors
um
the challenge
now is that is how do we analyze this
data appropriately and how do we
normalize them
we are still trying to tackle this issue
so my group is still now trying to as
many other groups in in the world is
trying to how to come up with
methodology that actually can uh
interpret the spatial statistic
correctly and robustly and I think um
with all these effort feel evolved
quickly and I I think in two or three
years probably this would become a real
clinical implication particularly for
immunotherapy uh I think that that can
get a very good weather for
immunotherapy type of response
I want to answer your question I know
that it doesn't give an answer but uh
that actually yeah
communication but we need to do more
work
yeah no that's that's perfect perfect
all right
um and with that I'd like to thank you
again Dr Chan for your time today and
for sharing your knowledge with us
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today as well
and for their extremely interesting
questions I'd also like to thank our
sponsor nanostring for sponsoring
today's webinar and just a note that
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
Dr Chan here via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
also this webcast will be viewed on
demand for two years so it's available
until October of 2024. lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay and we do encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
and with that
that end of our webinar and so until
next time goodbye